I have a voicemail to play for you of
course we have a voicemail number 219 to
david p is the voicemail this I like
this voicemail take a listen to this up
I like a program I can't figure out is a
stockbroker an investor call saying that
you David Pakman writers if you and I
don't think it is or is it your father
or borrowed name or see underwriting
your program okay and your sponsors they
all just actually invested in or you
invest you are you guys don't seem to
stand for anything you say the same
thing over and over again everybody else
is and your sidekick I can't tell
whether he's the brains behind you or
just for going along in your logo type
is no meaning no significance doesn't
stand for anything all those so
therefore you rather benign situation
okay the first of that so we'll work
backwards uh not everybody likes every
font and I know typeface is a really
really big deal to a lot of people so
you know up how can i comment about the
font that we're using in our logo that i
don't know about uh as far as the other
david pakman yeah he he is in a venture
capitalist for venrock I know him we've
known each other for a long time he is
David B Pakman and I am just david
pakman I've no middle name so there is
actually a difference there's a
different wiki page for him and for me
he's been in the news because he was one
of the early investors through venrock
in Dollar Shave Club which was recently
acquired by Unilever for a billion
dollar so he there's been a lot of
articles about him and it's caused a lot
of confusion he is not my dad I think
he's about 18 or so years older than me
um so maybe your dad Oh biologically he
could be my dad sure sure also Jews
don't do the junior thing and although
he's David B Pakman and I'm just david
pakman uh usually you don't have uh you
know Judas or bad luck it's considered
bad luck exactly to the extent anyone
believes in luck uh and
and dessert station superstition yeah
but traditionally Jews don't do the
junior thinks oh no he's not my dad
great guy he doesn't invest in the show
he is no affiliation with the show or
anything like that but glad glad we were
able to clear that up on the bonus show
today we've been talking about this for
a while and we now know who the first
head transplant patient will be we will
also talk about whether certain skills
are more heavily developed among men
than women and lastly we will talk about
the disaster that delta airlines had
yesterday and I i always have thoughts
about Delta Airlines you know that all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show today david pakman.com slash
membership is how you sign up for
instant access to the bonus show on the
brand new david pakman show website and
we still have six half price membership
coupons available the coupon code is
beta 50 B ETA 50 will speak to you then